here's our list of the top 10 most
anticipated films of the 2014 Cannes
Film Festival
number 10 still the water written and
directed by Naomi kawase kawase
previously directed Suzaku and the
mourning forest were itching to see her
style and skillset brought to another
cultural tell number 9 the rover written
and directed by David Mehcad Mekons
feature-length debut animal kingdom was
a breath of fresh air and the rover
looks to keep things that way and this
western set in a future down under a
loner tracks the gang who stole his car
from a desolate town in the Australian
outback Robert Pattinson guide Pierce
and scoot mcnairy are all great faces to
fit the desolate backdrop number 8 the
search written and directed by Michel
Hazanavicius hazanavicius won Best
Director and Best Picture Oscars for
2011's the artist the wickedly talented
bearnaise Bale plays an NGO employee who
forms a special relationship with a
young boy in war-torn Chechnya Annette
Bening co-stars in this modern retelling
of the 1948 friends liniment film of the
same name
number seven the salvation written and
directed by kristian levring in 1870s
America a peaceful American settler
kills his family's murderer which
Alisha's the fury of a notorious gang
leader Mads Mikkelsen
Eva Green jeffrey dean morgan and
jonathan pryce star in danish filmmaker
kristian levring stab at an american
western
number six Lost River written and
directed by Ryan Gosling Christina
Hendricks plays a single mother whose
son discovers an underwater utopia
considering goslings maturation as a
filmmaker and citing master David Lynch
as the direct influence were ready to
float down Lost River number five
Leviathan written and directed by Andres
fiag instead a present-day social drama
spanning multiple characters about the
human insecurities in a new country
which gradually unwinds to a
mythological scale concerning the human
condition on earth entirely frog instead
has been on our radar since his
masterful debut the return back in 2003
number four coming home directed by John
emo the story of a Chinese man who is
forced into marriage and flees to
America but when he returns home is sent
to a labor camp Li Gong and Chun dal
mean star in this heavy period piece
number three winter sleep written and
directed by Nuri bilge jalan-jalan spree
vyas film once upon a time in Anatolia
won the Grand Jury Prize at kin in 2011
plot details for winter sleep are a tad
scarce we're trusting Jalen and his past
collaborators on this one which happens
to be the longest film in competition
this year at 3 hours and 16 minutes
number two Foxcatcher directed by
banette Miller Miller of Capote and
Moneyball fame has a recognized gift for
bringing true stories of misunderstood
men to the big screen next in line is
paranoid schizophrenic John du Pont
whose life collided with the Olympic
wrestling duo the Schultz Brothers it's
Steve Carell and the role of DuPont that
has piqued our interests ever since the
film was first revealed and we look
forward to him acting opposite Channing
Tatum and Mark Ruffalo number one the
homesman written and directed by Tommy
Lee Jones with the homesman he plays a
claim-jumper opposite a pioneer woman
played by Hilary Swank who team up to
escort three mentally insane women from
Nebraska to Iowa we've never seen a
roadtrip movie like this before after
seeing the trailer for the homesman we
found ourselves wishing that Tommy Lee
Jones would just make westerns for the
rest of his career those are our top 10
most anticipated films for the 2014
Cannes Film Festival keep a tab open on
the movieclips Film Festival channel for
trailers clips and more and as always
thanks for watching
you
[Music]